all right kenny yes kenny which girl
where are you from originally jackson
mississippi jackson and uh tell me about
your childhood grown up you had mom and
dad
no i just had my mom my dad was had his
own family
you know my mom she struggled to take
care of
three boys three girls
how would you describe your childhood
pretty good
pretty good
no crazy abuse or anything like that
nothing crazy until i came to los
angeles
what when did what age did you come here
i made it here on december 25th 1992.
what kind of how how different was la
for for mississippi day and night what
kind of stuff is over the drastic
changes
for you it's fast
um
a lot of drugs
um
very disrespectful
the people just
disrespectful yeah you were in south
central that way yes yeah
it's the hood and it's it it's a
different world than mississippi totally
different world
i mean it's a different world from all
of la it's a different world from
everyone just a cold city to live in
yeah
if you can make it here you can make it
anywhere in the world yeah a lot of
violence a lot of games a lot of vows
there's a lot of games i'm okay with the
game part of it you know
it's a lot of snakes a lot of snakes
that's a great way of saying it you know
they're going to get you whatever way
they can to get you yeah
yeah you've had jobs
well when i first came here i worked for
robertson may
um
i got my income tax check
well i never got my income tax check
because they took it for child support
and since 93
i have not worked again
how you support yourself
i hustle
your hustle what kind of hustles
i'm a goal
in one detail but one detail i won't go
okay
all right now yeah i have sold a whole
lot of drugs you know yeah i have
transported i did a lot of that
but
when i was younger
17-18 i just smoked a lot of primos
you know
and which is cocaine and marijuana
no no heroin just scraped cocaine
rocks
they call it primos yeah but primo is i
thought cocaine mixed crack mixed with
uh
with weed right tobacco yeah so i did
that before i came here right but when i
got here
you get more for your money here
so i got deeper into my addiction even
though i was able to still maintain
like
how they see me right now and how i'm
looking because now i'm going i'm a lot
deep into my drugs
plus i'm going through a nasty
separation right now right now yeah
well you see now it's not
who they know out there in l.a know who
i am
you know you're going through a rough
patch
right now but i haven't been here before
you know i haven't been here before but
you climbed out
you climbed out of it before oh several
times yeah and i could see it gradually
coming because at one moment i just
didn't care any opinion i made
i would have got high with it
and being here in los angeles
you get more higher you get more higher
then you got to win me
tell me about the world don't help the
situation in it you know i be who i am
i make money every day
i may not smoke as many as much drugs as
money i say faster i got 800
i may spend 300 on the dope
but the female and got the rest of it
so i'm saying yeah and i never get a
chance to enjoy the drugs
it's a cold game
yeah so you so you'll you'll go down to
figaro street oh yeah
i i i go down there sometimes but i
don't really like those type of women
down there because they they pretty much
on the thirsty side
they half naked bro
so a lot of then you got to be careful
because you got some 16 to 17 year olds
down there yeah
it's prison that's what i say
how cold of a city this is
if you go down figaro
between two and three in the morning
i guarantee you'll see about 50
prostitutes on each side half naked
and i guarantee you like it's a parade
right
and the police don't do [ __ ] the police
drive right through it
they might be a part of it
yeah
that's how cold it is out here
it's a cold city man
you got in trouble down there
been arrested i just got caught up in a
an esteemed prostitution scheme
on western
i got caught on january the second on
the third
i didn't know she it was a sting i just
saw a white girl out there she was
undercover looking good on the cover i'm
smoking getting high
so i drive up
asked how she doing how much she charged
she said 100 i said really
i said yeah i said let me just drive
around so i drove around i didn't put up
on it i stopped like
maybe
two houses before the corner and i took
a hit of my [ __ ]
now come told me like is she the police
so i waved my hands come here come here
come here
and she was like
no come come now remind you
drugs crap it's all it's about a feeling
sex come with it oh horrified you you
know what i'm saying so when i took that
hit
now i'm just thinking about this female
i'm looking at this white girl now okay
i'm ready now so i just pull on up and i
let my wonder that's how you the police
she said no i'm not the police i said
you sure she said no now i'm looking at
this body
i just put on into the motel when i
pulled in police came from everywhere no
doesn't asking her if she's a cop and
she says no get you off
i don't know yet
i don't know that's why i'm not gonna
know i know that's entrapment but i
don't know until i go to court i've seen
all the girls ask if you're a cop and
they grab and squeeze your
your girls
she said no
hmm
well we'll see what happens in your case
exactly
i'm sorry about that exactly yeah but
how much will you spend on these girls a
week
well let me let me put it this way to
you at this moment and where i'm at i
just started back making a little money
um
right now they probably get 150
but now we can go back
a year
two years three years four years ten
years ago
i give them four five hundred dollars
because i treat them right
these dudes in la
they give them a hundred dollars fifty
dollars and they're gonna take that
money back and make them do anything
i heard a lot of cold stories that these
women's
and l.a has told me because the trust
out here
is bad
yeah it's hard to trust a [ __ ]
out here you can't trust anybody can't
trust me
and these women out here has been
through so much
i heard so many stories
i had heard so many students you hear me
they haven't been [ __ ] with a touch
uh right as a kid beating up robbed
everything oh man a lot of that yeah
these women have been through a lot and
i guess they call themselves nominee
cell
you know mm-hmm
i guess they call theirself numbing
themselves
yeah most jobs you would quit when
something like that happens but these
girls go right back to it because you
have to be numb to be out on cigarette
selling your [ __ ] sucking dicks you
know what i'm saying
around
people that you don't know hopefully
they took no shower two or three four
days
you have to have they have to have some
type of drugs in their system
in order to be out there
it's a crazy world crazy subculture down
there right now it's it's it's just
worse
it's bad yeah it's all kind of just like
me for instance
this is the longest i have been out
there getting loaded
and i've been lately i've been making
four five thousand four five hundred
dollars a day in three hours
what do i go to
drugs and a woman that i don't have sex
with got some too busy smoking dope
geeked up spooked yeah
when you're smoking crack you can't
really ride
you know what i'm saying because people
don't get whole at no way right
i've heard that that's real yeah
but but your desire is there it's down
so you want it you so you pay the girl
to stay yep but then i you take one so
if you think you're ready in two or
three minutes
back down
yeah
that's a cold life and cold drugs man
when they brought crack out
it's a cold drug but then a lot of them
even crack going to crystal meth
you know
i tried crystal mess
i didn't get nothing out of it
cracks your drug cracks my drug
you've been married
i'm going through a you're gonna ask
this separation right now
um
she hadn't filed for divorce yet i'm not
gonna file because
i love my benefits
you know
um
but if you do foul which i'm sure is
gonna happen sooner or later you know
we got property land in on arkansas
you know
i just want my partner because my money
was the one that bought it
i'm doing bad right now
[Music]
and i hope that i can get another
interview with you guys
set about
february march and things are better
it'll be a lot better
it's time for a chance you'll get some
money in hopefully
you're thinking
i'm not tripping on that
i'm telling you
your quality of life give myself back to
life because i live that life i have
lived a good life right
you're just having a down i'm having my
down down right now that's why i said i
would come back a couple more months
and i'll be who i am you'll feel
different now that don't stop me from
messing with them prostitutes were you
were you messing around with these girls
when you were married i did yeah i did
was that was that what killed the
marriage
huh was that what kind of broke up the
marriage well
when i told you i lived that life it's
like i just go to sam skip club
i just [ __ ] off
fifteen to two thousand dollars
two or three days out of the week
and
she want to know why was going to the
script club so much
must have been somebody and i was
[ __ ] but i didn't go to hook up with
none of those broads that's how i
entertained myself
i made good money
and i talked about how i maybe but i
made good money
and i still make a live right now
but i'm getting loaded with it i'm not
doing what i'm supposed to do with it
first four five hundred dollars i make i
stopped today
what regrets do you have
what regrets
she know my wife
with the same woman for eight years
put this girl um
in an apartment with her two kids took
care of her and her two kids for eight
years
and when i used to get mad at my wife i
go to her when she made me mad
so you were paying for an apartment for
another girl on the side
for seven years
and it just came to an end yeah
so i've been kind of [ __ ] up
it's hard for men to be faithful
sometimes isn't it
i said if i get another one that's good
i would try
i say i try
do you think humans are meant to be
monogamous
one partner
c
faithful that's a true thing
with men and women
we're two different creatures
because women works off of emotions
we don't work off emotion
it's just like
we can have something real good at home
when we see this pretty beautiful thing
god that made this woman
it's hard to just ignore it
but see women are different
they're just different they don't
understand us
because they're not a man
and we don't understand them
because they're a woman
they don't think like men think that men
don't think like women
so is the difference
yeah it's hard to be married for you a
man 20 30 40 years you're a man
so by you being a man she don't
understand how men think and you don't
understand what you don't know how women
think
we are different yeah
so like with our penis when we see
something they always say we think with
our opinions i got a divorce five years
ago
and it's whole after 17 years to me
if a man is always honest
and don't cheat on his wife
i don't see how you do it i want to know
how
how is this possible
i'm not saying
it's not out there
but i think it's very few of them
it does happen
i i just said i know it happens
but what the percentage of it would be
you won't know and i won't know
i think you have to grow with your
partner you have to challenge each other
you challenge yourself and just
i know some that come out i know
something did all that
and it didn't work yeah i know
even even if you do all that you still
crazy it happens [ __ ] happens we have we
humans you destroy great relationships
we humans
we're messy we're humans
[ __ ] happens
what's the most important thing you've
learned in your how old are you i'm 52.
what's the most important thing you've
learned in 52 years
let me say this to you
my daddy was a real good man
and i told you from the beginning of
this interview that
i had a good life as a kid
i can't complain
the way my dad
treated me
and how i fight him through his other
kids
that's what i did to my kids
i was a damn good father
and no matter when i was out here didn't
hide like i am now
i still came around you know
i was a good dad
i'm scared that
these drugs would [ __ ] you up
only the strong gonna survive
i'm in school don't survive
and i know i'm one of those strong ones
just go through what we go through yeah
but i'ma overcome it though this is the
longest i have
it's the longest i've been
my van got broke in they stole all my
clothes and shoes stole my cadillac
converter
you know what i'm saying i want to cry
got my laptop my printer
that's how i eat
that's all i know
when i once said when i stopped selling
drugs
all i loved was that paper day
you know
and it's just
for these last
six seven months been hard
in these last three weeks trying to get
a little bit better
i see the light coming though
no friends that's the coldest part about
it
no friends no friends
not hit one
that's hard
not a one
trust a [ __ ] l.a if you want to
you'll never make it
you never make it man
you will never make it
and it's hard because the drugs out here
it's so good
you know
the drugs is so good the crack is so
good and you get your money worth and
that's kind of like
makes it a little hard on you
but like i say i've been through this
before it's not my first time now my
second time not my third time
so i know i'ma beat it
but this time it's just taking a little
longer
forever for whatever reason that he was
because me using drugs going through a
divorce it's crazy
i don't even have transportation right
now i paid the money 500 to fix my car
two weeks ago i went back and got 500
oh wow i want to go get high money was
gone about four five hours
i spent 100 some dollars bro i got the
rest of it
and got left in the motel
cold game man
but most of these [ __ ] in l.a would be
abroad up
i'm not going to put my hand on the
broad
i can't even point like
that's what i'm not gonna
welcome to l.a man
cold city
it's cold city out here
all right kenny well thank you so much
for sharing your story thank you come
check it check in with me in six months
and let's see where you're at i will
thank you man
you